[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILIP: Hello, everyone.
This is another episode
of the "Boring Show"
with your favorite
hosts, Emily and me.
EMILY: Favorite?
FILIP: Yeah.
And today, we're going to talk
about the good old Hacker News
app that some of you might
remember from way earlier.
We decided to
revisit it because--
EMILY: There was some clean-up
that needed to be done.
FILIP: Yeah.
EMILY: And people had a
couple of questions about--
FILIP: That's true.
EMILY: --things we
wanted to [INAUDIBLE]
off the rough edges.
FILIP: And also, yeah, we
have some plans for it,
which we'll keep secret for now.
So, Emily, you looked at
it, and it was broken.
EMILY: Yeah, so
I synced the repo
and tried to run Footer
Run, and it didn't build.
And the reason is because Dart
2 has come out, and basically,
a lot of our dependencies--
package dependencies
in our pub spec
allowed you to go
up to everything
but the next major
version number.
That's-- if you have
that little caret thing.
Maybe you can put the pub spec.
But yeah, so that caret
syntax means everything up
to the next major
version number.
FILIP: So not 7.0.
EMILY: Right.
And because, with Dart 2
coming out, a bunch of things
bumps there major
version number.
And since we're
running Dart 2 locally,
everything was like, I can't
solve these constraints.
So I had to tweak
the constraints
on a couple different
things, and mainly, it
consisted of looking at
what the latest package
number was in pub.
If you want to not deal with all
of that, another way to do it
is just to use the
greater than or equals
to and then those numbers,
and that will always
take anything larger, including
the next version number.
FILIP: So yeah,
so basically this,
and then we realized that
Build Runner has to be--
EMILY: Yes, so I made a--
that actually just updated, and
that required a slight tweak
in Build Runner's pub specs.
So I sent them a pull
request, and they actually
just updated it.
So I haven't-- right now, it's
pointing to my forked version
of the repository.
FILIP: Which is a
good point to make,
is if you are depending on
someone or something, and you--
the pub version is not the most
current version, for example,
or you're tweaking it a
little bit just to make sure,
you don't need to just
use the version number.
If you just use
the version number,
it will just go to [INAUDIBLE]
and get the version there.
But you can also say, you know
what, I want this from Git
from this particular URL.
You can even say the
comment hash, I think,
and you can even use path.
So you can just clone
it to yourself--
you can do whatever you
want with the library
or with the package,
and then point to it
with the path instead
of Git or anything else.
EMILY: Yeah, it can
point to a local path
on your machine,
which is actually
what I did before
I committed this,
and I was like, Filip
needs to use it.
He doesn't have access
to my local machine.
Actually, do you
want to edit out--
or change one of
the numbers back
to what it was just so they can
see what the error message is?
Pub will tell you what the
particular packages are
that it's having problems with.
FILIP: This was dev
dependency 0.8.0?
EMILY: Sure.
FILIP: That's the
thing that-- well, OK.
EMILY: Instead of 1.0, yeah.
FILIP: 0.8.0 and put get--
oh, look, "the current dot
SDK version 2.1," because--
EMILY: This is actually a
little bit of a complicated one,
but the error is saying
that Build Runner, up
to the next major
version number,
1.0, requires the Dart SDK
to be less than Dart 2.0.
And because we're
running Dart 2.0,
we can't run that
version of Build Runner.
Therefore, we have to update
our Build Runner version.
FILIP: So we do that
again, and then this
should be back to normal.
EMILY: And it's great, yes.
FILIP: All right, everything
works like last time,
so if you haven't seen our
previous Flutter "Boring Show"
with the Hacker News app--
EMILY: You have lots of
exciting footage to catch up on.
FILIP: Yes, yes.
But this is-- spoiler alert--
this is the app that we get to,
and it works.
I think it's almost ready
to publish on Play Store.
So all right, let's--
that's the--
EMILY: Is that the spoiler?
FILIP: --dependency encryption.
Another spoiler.
So that's the
dependency problem,
and then we wanted
to just check--
EMILY: A couple of warnings.
FILIP: Couple of warnings, yes.
So we have some
warnings in the code
that we just left there
because we're lazy.
EMILY: Oh, I thought they were
because they didn't show up
with Dart.
FILIP: Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
We were just lazy.
EMILY: [INAUDIBLE].
FILIP: Yes.
So first of them is,
this class inherits
a class marked immutable.
So basically what
it's saying that,
you know what, your
loading info class
is extending stateful widget,
and that needs to be immutable.
The widget itself is immutable.
Then the state,
obviously, is not,
but the widget
itself is immutable.
And yet you have a string
that can be reassigned.
EMILY: Dun-dun-dun.
FILIP: Yeah, so we just do this.
Not file-- final.
And that disappears.
So if you have a thing
that is-- and by the way,
I wanted to show you--
hey.
Oh, this is how you would say I
want my class to be immutable,
and then everything
inside the class
must be either
[INAUDIBLE] or final.
You are not allowed to have
free assignable things in there.
So that's fixed.
Next one, we have a stream
controller here, and it says,
actually, you should close all
instances of Dart core sync,
which is very helpful
because that's--
sometimes, people will forget.
And even though in our
case, because our--
this is our block, and our block
lives for the whole duration
of the app.
So we don't really care, but
it's obviously better practice
to close syncs in general.
So what we can do is
just add a close method
and close the string here.
And then just make
sure that we--
anytime we get rid of the block,
which we don't right now, we
will just do block.close.
EMILY: So is Hacker News--
oh, it's not a--
I was going to say, if
it's a stable widget,
then you can do it
on [INAUDIBLE]----
FILIP: Yeah, yeah.
No, this is just a class.
Yeah, yeah.
So I also just
sorted everything.
EMILY: So in theory, you
could call that close method
when the last widget--
the widget that is
using the block is done.
FILIP: That's true, but that's--
basically, that would
be the app widget.
And then the app
widget is stateless,
and stateless
don't have dispose.
And we really want this to
be on for the whole duration
of the app.
If this was a
block for something
that we create, like a page, and
then we don't need it anymore,
then yes, we have
our dispose method,
and in our dispose
method, we would just
be calling close of everything
that we need to close.
So that's one, and
the third one is
here, which just says
this function has
a return type of feature--
of article, but doesn't end
with a return statement.
It does end with
a return statement
if everything is grayed, but if
there is something happening,
then it's just--
EMILY: [INAUDIBLE] getting bad.
FILIP: Right, so
we can do either
like returning a dummy article
or something that kind of tells
us somewhere else that
this has gone wrong.
But again, we're lazy,
so we'll just throw--
what?
Which kind of errors?
EMILY: Is there-- ooh.
FILIP: [INAUDIBLE]
network error right now.
EMILY: Stad something?
FILIP: StateError?
I just default to StateError.
I mean, we--
EMILY: You should do Error.
FILIP: Just Error?
Wow.
EMILY: Let's not do that.
Yeah-- mm?
FILIP: Well, you know what?
EMILY: StateError.
FILIP: Nah.
Class--
EMILY: Oh.
FILIP: Yes.
Class Hacker News--
EMILY: Wow.
FILIP: API error.
EMILY: I was just going to
be like, what about HTTP
error or something like that?
FILIP: Yeah, but
it's not really that.
EMILY: It is.
FILIP: The underlying one--
oh.
EMILY: That's what
causes the problem,
is because we didn't get the
right result we expected,
so we can't find it.
FILIP: Right, but is it there?
EMILY: There's-- OK, you--
I'll search.
FILIP: I mean-- right,
OK, I'll do my thing.
So Hacker News-- so we could
do final String message,
and Hacker News API error,
as with this message,
and that's it.
So we can actually-- now that we
made our own error, so article
ID couldn't be fetched.
EMILY: [INAUDIBLE], yeah.
FILIP: Now, we can actually
try to catch that exact error,
and it will--
so while we are actually
using this, we can do--
EMILY: Try catch.
FILIP: Try catch [INAUDIBLE].
So we don't have any more
warnings, which is great.
Yes, we could use a preexisting
error, but this [INAUDIBLE]..
EMILY: [INAUDIBLE].
FILIP: All right,
so everything works.
We had a question.
What if you have--
this is about blocks, so
this is the architecture
that we were using for
this particular app.
That's basically, having a
component that has only streams
as inputs and syncs as--
sorry, streams as outputs
and sync as inputs.
And for this, the
question was, what
if I have two different blocks
or three different blocks--
how do they communicate
to each other?
And so there is no
single perfect answer--
to any architectural
question, by the way.
But what I've seen so far is--
and what Google
uses internally is
that you're trying
to not pass one
block to another as a
dependency, but instead,
you're using the streams
as inputs and the syncs--
I'm sorry, syncs as inputs
and streams as outputs,
and just put them together.
EMILY: Producer-consumer.
FILIP: Yes, yes.
You're just piping
the blocks together,
which sometimes,
that means that you
will have to add new
either outputs or inputs,
just in order to
put these in sync.
But it's way-- it's way easier
than to just put something out,
maybe even pull the block
away and not use it and so on.
EMILY: So are you suggesting
adding to the API of the block
specifically?
FILIP: Yes, if you need that.
Sometimes, you don't.
Sometimes, you're just like,
oh, that other block is just
listening to some of the
outputs that I already have.
And it shouldn't
be-- again, if it
looks too complicated
and too overengineered,
it probably is,
so make it simple
and make it just for your app.
We're actually kind of--
EMILY: More than
needed for this.
FILIP: Yeah, we're
doing something
that's a little too
overengineered for something
as simple as this.
So that's the question.
And then we just realized that
this is a really good Hacker
News reader, but it
always reads just a set--
EMILY: Five articles.
FILIP: Yes, five articles
because we're actually--
I don't know exactly
why we did this.
Probably just because
we're lazy, again.
But we just added these and
hardcoded these into the app,
so what we want
to do is actually
get them through our
amazing method that
is called parseTopStories.
And then use them to
get the latest articles.
EMILY: Why is the JSON
string hardcoded there?
Oh, this is a test?
FILIP: Yeah, this
is just a test.
I just wanted to--
yes.
All right, so let
me see the top IDs.
Where do we use them here?
Get articles and update.
Oh, that's because--
EMILY: Yeah, we put it
into the article stream.
[INAUDIBLE]
FILIP: So we need Get IDs.
That would be a future
of a list of ints.
So Future of List
of Integers, getIds,
and then we should tell if it's
a top stories or news stories,
I think.
Yeah, so it should
be stories type,
so we should give
it a stories type,
and this is an async
method because we'll
be calling the API.
For now, we're just going
to come out and do this.
EMILY: Oh, so I just looked
up the Hacker News API,
and it looks like it's
just this URL here.
FILIP: Right, yes, I'll
need this in a minute.
I just want to make sure
that-- so we can do that.
And now, how do we use this?
So we want getIds of Story Type
Top, and that's a list of IDs.
Oh, and we need
to [INAUDIBLE] it.
EMILY: Oh, no, but
you're in a constructor.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
EMILY: So you will probably want
to write a helper function that
is asynchronous.
Now, do we need this Get
Articles update to be
completed before this happens?
FILIP: No, no.
It's just the first--
EMILY: OK.
FILIP: Yeah, so future void--
which is also something
that we didn't have before.
We have future void now.
EMILY: As of Dart 2.0.
FILIP: So just--
EMILY: Initialize?
FILIP: Initialize--
EMILY: Articles.
FILIP: Articles.
And that said, it's just async
because we want to do this.
And now, we can
call it from here.
EMILY: Yeah.
FILIP: So just so that
we are not losing anyone,
what we did is we realized,
we want to use async--
or await in constructor,
and constructors cannot be
asynchronous.
They need to be synchronous.
So we could do the
getIds dot [INAUDIBLE]
and do it the old way,
but we want to use async.
So instead, we just call this
thing that will do this for us,
and we don't care that
it will finish sometime
after the creation of this whole
thing because we don't care.
This will get the article
sometime in the future
and give it to us.
EMILY: Yeah, and we'll
listen to the stream,
and when the articles
appeared, then we
can do things with them.
But until then, I think
we have a default--
FILIP: I wonder
if I can do this.
Can I?
Oh, OK.
And so this is the same
thing, so await, get IDs of--
that one is news stories?
Actually, I can just do await.
EMILY: Hm?
FILIP: I have the
Stories Type here,
so I can do await
of Stories Type.
I don't need the
switch here anymore.
See?
Goes Stories Type,
Stories Type--
EMILY: Yes.
FILIP: Yes, OK.
EMILY: Great.
FILIP: All right, and
now to fix the getId.
Where is it?
So you told me that there
is a URL at Hacker News.
EMILY: Yeah, so see, this
one is Hacker News Item,
and so the difference
of this one
is it's slash v0 slash top
stories versus new stories.
FILIP: OK, so--
EMILY: Yeah, item-- not item,
top stories, new stories,
dot JSON.
FILIP: V0 top stories
or news stories.
EMILY: Mm-hmm.
FILIP: OK, so final--
EMILY: What are you trying to--
oh, like base URL?
FILIP: Yeah.
EMILY: Oh.
FILIP: Oh, yeah,
or part URL base.
EMILY: Yeah, what is it called?
Piece?
There's a name for that.
Can't remember.
FILIP: Time equals Stories Type,
Top Stories, then it's Top,
and otherwise, it's New?
EMILY: Yeah.
FILIP: This is kind of
hacky, but you get the point.
So URL, and then?
EMILY: Dot JSON.
It's just--
FILIP: [INAUDIBLE] top stories?
EMILY: New stories, yeah.
FILIP: Top stories
or new stories.
Correct?
EMILY: Yes.
FILIP: Stories.JSON.
EMILY: Yep.
FILIP: So we have URL.
EMILY: And if you really wanted,
you could take out this--
that chunk of
hacker-news.firebase v0,
and then make that a constant.
FILIP: So like a static const
of base URL is this or this.
EMILY: Yeah, yeah.
FILIP: This.
And why don't we just
do base URL and OK.
And this.
[INAUDIBLE] using braces?
EMILY: You don't need to because
it's just the [INAUDIBLE]..
FILIP: Oh, that's true.
EMILY: Yeah.
Great.
FILIP: OK.
So we have the URL, and
then we get the contents
of the URL, so basically, this.
EMILY: Yeah, you
did JSON Decode?
FILIP: Final response is
await of HTTP get URL,
and then I think we already--
we're parsing this
in the stories.
What did I do?
No.
EMILY: I do.
I do.
FILIP: So just parse top
stories on the string.
EMILY: Great.
FILIP: Are we
getting the string?
No.
EMILY: Response.body.
FILIP: On the body, OK.
So again, we'll
probably If Story--
sorry, If Response Status
Code does not equal 200,
then we probably want to
throw our amazing new--
EMILY: Specialized [INAUDIBLE]
Hacker News API error.
FILIP: And we say Stories
couldn't be fetched.
Now, we know that status
code is 200, so we can--
EMILY: Return.
FILIP: Parse top
stories from the stream.
EMILY: Response.body.
FILIP: Our response.body.
And that's it.
EMILY: Return, yeah.
FILIP: Cool.
So what do we think?
EMILY: Yeah, let's--
FILIP: Let's try it.
EMILY: See if we
get updated stories.
Ooh.
FILIP: Connection failed.
EMILY: Too many open files?
FILIP: What?
OK, what?
Is there anything--
so we're trying
to get a bunch of
articles at once, maybe.
Is that--
EMILY: Oh, are we--
maybe-- so right.
So this says this
returns up to 500,
so maybe we want to
just limit that to 10.
FILIP: Yeah.
How do we tell it
to get just 10?
EMILY: Oh, well, I don't--
I think it'll
return all of them,
but we just don't have
to process them all.
FILIP: Ah, that's true.
EMILY: So we can just
like get a subset.
FILIP: Right.
So wherever we are doing
this, we'll just do--
EMILY: Oh, how about
in parseTopStories?
FILIP: Like this?
EMILY: Sure.
FILIP: To list.
EMILY: OK, yeah.
Does parseTopStories
make [INAUDIBLE]---- no,
it just makes a list.
OK, yeah.
Great.
Woo-hoo.
FILIP: Let's see if this
is actually a new story.
But it should be at Bloomberg.
EMILY: All right.
FILIP: September, nice.
EMILY: OK, so what
we did is we did a--
we updated, so we're not using
hardcoded Hacker News stories.
We're pulling them live
from the Hacker News API.
We added-- talked a
little bit about block,
if you have multiple
blocks, inputs and outputs.
We talked about
version controlling
with updating your pub spec.
And I think there's one more.
FILIP: No, I think--
EMILY: No?
FILIP: I think-- oh, we--
EMILY: Oh, fixing warnings.
FILIP: Yes.
EMILY: Great.
Stay tuned for-- we're going to
work on caching for the Hacker
News app next.
[MUSIC PLAYING]